voilà il ya plus rien maintenant il faut
ranger on va arranger pour en finir et
puis pour oublier on va on va chercher à
faire autre chose et les sortir de là
parce que d'ici une semaine ou deux
j'aurais même que l' envie de revenir
ici le constat est terrible pour jordan
moon est agriculteur dans les landes
depuis 2013 il a dû fermer son élevage
de 17000 canard à cause d'un diagnostic
d'épidémie de grippe aviaire
c'est la cinquième fois que la région
est touchée par le virus qui coûtent la
vie à des centaines de canards et qui
frappe les éleveurs au porte-monnaie
pour jordan les pertes s'élèvent à plus
de cent mille euros depuis plusieurs
jours il passe son temps à nettoyer le
matériel qui servait à nourrir ses bêtes
un véritable crève coeur pour
l'agriculteur de la colère envers tous
ceux qui apprennent les décisions pour
nous du dévouement envers les animaux de
voir que une fois depuis sont pas en
fait partir sa la poubelle comme comme
si c'était rien quoi et de la lenteur
envers notre famille c'est parce qu'au
final on est incapable de d'assumer
notre rôle et fonction qu'on a de
soutenir une famille
son travail 9 points dans l'année jordan
mounette ne peut même pas profiter de
toutes les aides possibles de l'état
si chaque animal abattu a été payé tout
le coût sanitaire ne l'a pas été ce qui
va l'obliger à se lancer dans l'intérim
en attendant la reprise de son activité
le constat est le même pour lionel
candelon éleveur et président de
l'association canard en colère
tout son élevage a été abattu à cause de
la propagation du virus dans le gers un
bilan désastreux qui se répète alors que
la solution est simple pour
l'agriculteur il faut vacciner
vacciner en masse pour ne plus subir de
tels drames j'en ai marre parce que ça
fait depuis 2017 2018 notamment qu on
demande qu'on exige le vaccin contre la
grippe aviaire pour nos animaux un
vaccin qui est fabriqué en france par le
laboratoire de libourne et pour la
cinquième année consécutive les
autorités ne veulent pas entendre parler
du vaccin et j'ai pas envie que l'année
prochaine si on
si on n'a pas le vaccin on revienne
euthanasie mes canards jeu là c'est la
dernière année c'est la fois de trop là
il faut que ça s'arrête maintenant parce
qu'on va pas vivre ça chaque chaque
hiver c'est pas possible ces pertes ont
des répercussions terribles pour des
centaines d'éleveurs en france
sur les cinq dernières années c'est plus
de 20 millions de canards qui ont été
abattus dans le gers